right good morning everyone and welcome
to the town hall bford and those joining
us on YouTube for the February 2024
plans committee meeting there is no
planned fire drill for this morning but
should the alarm go off please leave the
build in the way that you came up and do
not use the lift I would just like to
ask the committee members to introduce
themselves by stating their name and the
ward that they represent and likewise
can the officers introduce themselves so
I start from my
left Chris weatley sh and lry
Ward oh must be the Magic Touch I'm
sorry chair and councelor Louis Bar West
with hward and I'm here today
substituting for councelor Doug Smith
thank you very much thank you everybody
peterward
Thomas Philip Paddington monley and
putford good morning everybody Chris
leather
Norther
everyone good morning Doug push bford
North and I'm subbing for councelor k
good morning I'm Kirsty Brown Democratic
Services officer good morning I'm Stacy
Dory head of legal governance good
morning rosemy lot representing two
rivers and three Ms good morning I'm
Helen Smith planning
manager morning Chrissy V development
manager right so moving on to the agenda
item number one
apologies thank you chair so apologies
from councelor Christie with councelor
Thomas
substituting apologies from councel heel
with councel bushby substituting and
apologies from Council Smith with
Council bark
substituting thank you very much item
number two Declarations of Interest
members with interested declare should
refer to the agenda item and describe
the nature of their interests when the
item is being considered elected members
of Ste County Council and town and
Parish councils who have considered the
plan and application by virtue of their
membership of that Council hold a
personal interest and are deemed to have
considered the application separately
and the express views of that council do
not bind the members concerned who
consider the application of fresh which
may include further
information item number three agreements
between Parts one and two we have no
part two item number four urgent matters
I have none
yes Council hes may I be allowed to
speak please chair if you're going to
speak about middle Doc is not on the
agenda so if you there have been lots of
emails that our solicitor and our
planning manager have circulated and if
you have any problems please address
them to Shan cley and bring it to full
csil or CNR um I did ask you chair
whether I could speak earlier I thought
that that was appropriate and is quite
important no it's not on the agenda so
if you've got anyone you know address
your concerns to Sean for Council or
CNR thank you
you item number five public
participation the order of speaking is
as
follows a member of the town or Parish
Council two members of the public
against two members of the public in
support and all of the above have three
minutes each and finally the war of
member Ma speak and they are not limited
to 3 minutes I will read out the names
of those ready to speak as of when we
come to each
application so item number six going on
to the plan and
applications first application is
application
a159 23 non-material
Amendment the reposition of modular
units at Sally house and it's on pages 5
to8 of your agenda are there any
Declarations of
Interest I suppose we should all declare
an interest as members of
TTC right the officer will now get the
presentation thank you chair um so this
um might take a bit of explaining in a
minute but I'll run through the
presentation first so this is for a
non-material Amendment um next
slide that's the site so it's um sort of
on the the the cown industrial estate um
it's land that we own um and it's
currently used temporary accommodation
next
slide that's a nice aerial photo um if
you can orientate yourself before
hopefully you can now um next
slide that's the building um it's um as
I said it's various temporary
accommodation
units next
slide that's the the back of the
building or the front I'm not really
sure but that's the um that's the car
park um entrance which is to the north
um next
Slide the temporary accomodation units
um which you can see there so the
morular units the they're what you're
considering today in particular the
yellow units that you can see there so
um next
slide um it just shows the relationship
between the two um so the blue ones are
as approved the yellow ones are in a
slightly different position so this
application seeks to regularize where
it's been put next
slide um you can see here so you've got
this sort of car park and you can see
the two modular units this is what was
approved and this was approved by
members
before um at planning committee um you
can see the units face onto each other
okay um so if if you look very carefully
it's a bit of a gam Spot the Difference
um but it is in a sort of Red Cloud so
if we go to the next slide you can see
that's that's orientated around so if we
go backwards again you can see that and
then
forwards so you can see that's turned
around okay um now our Estates team tell
me that that's firstly due to some
privacy points and secondly due to um
having to effectively have shorter pipes
so that it you can retain heat into
those units slightly
easier next slide now I'm sorry if I'm
going to chat a load of planning jargon
to you now um some of this might go over
your head hopefully some of it was sink
in um the what
your some some of this um what you're
considering isn't a new planning
application okay there's a procedure
called a non-material Amendment and what
that allows is for a plan to be
substituted for another plan so this is
a nonmaterial amendment to an existing
planning application that exists so
you're not approving a new planning
consent what you're effectively doing is
you're saying okay we can add this plan
in and we can build in accordance with
this plan instead okay now the
consideration for nonmaterial Amendment
application isn't the the same as a
planning application so in a planning
application you have the material
considerations which are highways
amenity all of those usual things that
you're used to considering a non
material Amendment application what you
have to consider is is this change
significant in any kind of way does it
does it cause an impact okay and if it
doesn't then what we can say is it's
nonmaterial if you say it isn't
non-material then they need to apply a
new planing application okay what what
the the procedure was introduced
effectively to try and cut some red tape
and get stuff through in a quick and
efficient um and cheap manner really to
allow people to make some minor changes
to
plans um so when you're considering this
in any kind of
discussion that's all you're considering
does this cause any additional impacts
to what was already
considered if if you have any questions
feel free to ask I hope I've explained
that in the most simple way possible um
and back to you please
CH thank you very much so I've got no no
registered speakers so I open up the
matter for discussion who'd like to
kick yeah well it it always was a
procedure that any possible non
nonmaterial amendments were put to the
chair and vice chair of the committee
for deciding whether it's a minor or a
major Amendment or whether it would need
a completely new planning
application I don't know
why why the chair and vice chair weren't
considered on their view on
their on their on their view on it and
made a decision rather than having to
print all this and I'll move the
recommendation to Grant it anyway
there's no issue with it at all is
it
um as you say chair it's because it's a
torage district council application and
in the interests of transparency I
assume that's why it's come here
transparency is an important issue thank
you
chair thank you CH councelor
back councelor
bushby councelor hes councelor leather
four councelor lock for councelor
Penington councelor Thomas councelor
Wheatley councelor Whitaker that's
unanimous
chair application B on your agenda is
application number one stroke dou1
14623 outline for one dwelling with all
matters reserved at Newton St Petr and
it's on pages 9 to 17 of your agenda are
there any Declarations of Interest
please no so the officer will now get
the
presentation um oh where is Deb yeah the
the Case Case officer isn't here so I I
I I will run through the presentation
but please bear in mind I'm not the case
officer but I am aware of the
application you're happy with that I'm
more than happy with that thank you very
much okay so so yes this this
application was subject to a site visit
back in um January and it is an outline
application with all matters reserved
for one dwelling and um it's it's at
land um the grid reference is set out
there on the slide um the nearest sort
of settlement of note is Newton Newton
Petro there is a verbal update date um
there there has there was a consult te
response from Newton St Petro Parish
Council um which is set out on on the
slide above I believe this was um
unintentionally emitted from your agenda
report so the Paris Council have
indicated local needs requirement
comments the parish meeting expressed
General outline support for the
development of the proposed plot as the
design and plan evolves the parish would
wish to see um a the retention of the
maximum amount of Devon bank and hedging
facing the road as possible and B the
preservation of a Young Oak Tree
situated at the fieldgate the likely
access to the plot the parish would also
point out that reported Japanese not
weed is present in the bank between the
road and the field in a position close
to the site so that's exactly as was
provided by the parish
council so now just running through the
slides and again um those who were at
the site visit will will have will be um
familiar with the site the site um is
located within the wider Parish of
Newton St Petr on the right hand slide
right hand image there the site is
actually outlined with a red rectangle
I'll just zoom in on that slightly um so
it does form part of an existing
agricultural
field it is um I believe approximately
1.6 kilm to the north of Newton Petro
which you can see on the bottom of the
image um Newton petrock is a rural
settlement um and then you can see the
a388 runs along the sort of Northern to
to the north of the site I believe it's
around 100 meters to the north of the
application site and you can see STI
cross which is a village as in
identified in our local plan which is up
to the northeast of the
site now these these are the plans that
were submitted with the application it
is submitted in outline with all matters
reserved so there is there is no detail
um at all before you for consideration
today other than these two plans which
are a location plan and a site plan
there is no indicative site plan to show
how a dwelling could be provided on site
and Associated means of access and
drainage Etc so as can be seen from the
location plan which is on the left hand
side the site does sit
to the southern end of a group of
dwellings they have no settlement status
certainly not in our local plan they
would not be classed as a rural
settlement under the local plan um
definition um the the site plan to the
right shows in a little more detail the
relationship with existing built form um
and this was obviously discussed in in
some well shown in some detail during
the site visits
um and you can see I believe it's
coldfield house which is on the opposite
side of the road I think sort of corner
to corner of plots is is around sort of
um 10 MERS to to the dwelling and then
on the same side of the road there is an
open field
gate um and and a field IM immediately
adjoining with the ne sort of built form
I believe sort of 30 to 40 meters to the
north there is an out building and then
a dwelling um so it so it is it is cited
on the edge of a group of of dwellings
which which are set around the junction
on the
a388 and again that aerial photo
hopefully shows that relationship with
the the group of dwellings um for
you now just running through some photos
the photo on the left shows the existing
fieldgate into the the field that forms
part of this
application um again there's no detail
of access before before members to today
so the red line does extend across the
frontage there so it's not to say that
this is where the access would be and
then the field on the right is within
the site um there is a sort of overgrown
area which you can see and um there is a
sort of an old shed type structure
within that overgrown area which is very
small scale and you can see cofi house
just to the left of that image and the
the other sort of I think just slightly
the RS of dwellings maybe
Beyond so this is just some street view
images now um again that's the same
Gateway and and the same property which
sits on the opposite side this is
viewing from the
south and this is now just heading
slightly further across the site is
immediately on the right here so this is
the sort of edge of the site and you can
see um the built form just
beyond now this is looking back towards
the South so C F house on the right you
can just about make out the overgrown
area where the shed is located so the
the proposed dwelling would be would be
beyond that that hedge and you can see
just immediately in the foreground here
the boundary and then the entrance way
into the field that that sits um to the
immediate north of the
site and this is slightly further back
again looking South to show show the
site and its relationship with existing
built
form and this is the view from The a388
Junction um the the site is
approximately 100 100 meters from this
point as raised at the site visit by the
case office there there is no um sort of
authorized bus stop along this road at
this point um whilst there is a bus that
runs along this road the nearest
stopping points are some distance away
um and this has been confirmed by the
bus operator so it's
it's there isn't an easily walkable
convenient bus stop and access to public
transport so just quickly running
through the material considerations um
these are obviously all set out in
detail in your a Agenda Report in
respect to the principle of development
policy st7 part four is is your your
main policy of relevance here the site
does not form part of a settlement as
recogn ized in our rural spatial
strategy and in our settlement hierarchy
it is an open Countryside or Countryside
location The Proposal is for an open
market dwelling and there is no policy
support for such a proposal in this
location hence um the officers report
identifies conflict with policy
st74 in terms of character and
appearance again concerns have been
raised around given there is no
principal support that the introduction
of a dwelling in this location orbe it
without any details before you today
members would would give rise to an
further encroachment into the
countryside in a location that doesn't
support residential development
neighboring amenity there's no objection
raised on that Master there's not
believed to be any potential subject to
design at any detailed stage for harm to
neighbors um the Environmental
Protection Officer has recommended
conditions should there be a grant of
approval relating to hours of operation
for construction um and also around
contamination needing to be um surveyed
prior to commencement of any development
environmental impact and
drainage the application has been
supported by percolation testing and
it's it's considered and um supported by
the Environmental Protection office that
um the land would be suitable for a
private drainage provision so there's no
objections in principle albeit the
detail would need to come forward at a
later stage highway safety again it's
considered that appropriate Highway
access could be achieved however that in
terms of visibility and the positioning
of an access would be again for the
detailed stage and finally ecology
um again there there's there's no
objections there is there is potential
through appropriate boundary treatments
whilst there would most likely be a loss
of an element of hedge R to create an
access that further hedge R could be
provided by means of a boundary around
the site um so to conclude the the
application fundamentally on the grounds
of of conflict with our spatial strategy
for the rural areas is recommended for
refusal thank you
chair thank you Helen I now go to the
public speaking list our first risent
speaker is Sarah bridan if you'd like to
come down to the front you have three
minutes to
speak if you'd like to sit down and put
the microphone on
yeah good morning members of the council
firstly I would like to thank you for
allowing me the opportunity to speak
today as you are already aware we are
seeking plan permission for a proper you
to say petrock the reasoning behind us
applying is due to us wanting to be in
the community that I grew up in and to
have a substantially better family life
of our children by doing so the area of
the land in which we're applying for
planning has belonged to my family for
decades a family of which over this time
has contributed to the local community
and provided it also with a local
business I have not been able to remain
in that Community as there is little
property that becomes available for
young families on our feedback it states
that there is no public transport which
you have just touched on but I'd like to
discuss that although the bus stop is
not on the official bus route the bus
stop there does stop at least two to
three times a day and collects people
and drops them off we've applied at this
site due to there already being a small
settlement of properties around here
which have been developed over the past
30 years we have taken into
consideration the neighboring properties
and would ensure that a property here
would not have any negative impact on
them or affect any of their
surroundings we have noted noted that
the comment on our application in
respect of ensuring that the site
remains clean and tidy would not have an
adverse impact on the drains we would be
fully aware of this during the build and
would ensure that nobody would be
affected
negatively this would be a self-build
project and we would ensure that all
neighboring properties were happy at all
times adding to this having a property
at this site would enable my partner to
continue to grow his Building Company by
being able to store his equipment safely
with us on site and then be able to
commute to the local areas with ease and
create more opportunities with expansion
I work work in residential child care
which provides 24 hours wraparound care
we in the local area do not have any
child care facilities and I rely on my
parents to be able to provide the child
care that we need to be able to work
with this being close to them where we
can walk across the field reduces the
need for transport and ease for both
parties and as they grow older we can
also easily meet their needs of Support
also currently at the site there is a
deric shed with overgrown areas
surrounding it I therefore personally
believe that removing this would benefit
the surroundings and the appearance on
the notes it explains how we would need
to remove some hedge grow to enable some
safe entrance to the property and this
would be compensated for as after would
be planting new hedge R across the whole
of the border of the property allowing
the wildlife to continue to thrive with
extra habitat areas by building this
property will be improving the quality
of development for this area with the
property being sustainable and of a high
quality build and also using renewable
energy sources which properties of this
area currently do not benefit from the
primary school and secondary school pass
is the entrance for this site for my
children and the bus stop that is at the
end of the road also commutes to petrock
college for further education I would be
very grateful for you to take into
account all of these aspects when coming
into your decision as you and I know
this environment for my children to grow
in will benefit their lifestyle and
mental health as they grow into
adulthood as it did mine my boys want to
be able to kick a football and ride
around the fields as we did thank you
very much for your time well Don that
was dead on three
minutes
right our next Regent speaker is the war
member councelor K
hin dear counselors I've been on the
council for more than six years now I
know you can't I've got all the gray
hairs to show for it as well and I think
I can say that this is the first
planning application that I've ever
called in asking counselors to support
I'm usually on the other side asking
counselors to refuse
applications however this one really
stands out to me as being one that is
really worthy of our support and I hope
you will all agree too I have given
quite a lot of detail in the call into
committee which you will have already
read and is printed in the report this
includes the fact that it actually fits
in well alongside a number of other
properties and as we've seen in the
photos on the edge of the small Hamlet
at Newton St Petro cross which Accords
with planning policy
dm24 it forms part of a small closely
grouped built form of housing also that
the applicants as we've just heard are a
local couple who both grew up in the
area and have their family and support
system living there which Accords with
st19 for exception sites and identified
local needs to justify it I refused the
officer's notion that this is not
sustainable it is located on the school
bus route for their two young children
who attend the small local Village
School nearby and the children's
grandparents who also live in Newton St
Petri who help with daily Child Care
needs Mr Davey also uses an area of Mr
and Mrs Bridgeman's land as a base for
his carpentry business in Newton St Petr
and travels there every day to get what
he needs for his job I there therefore I
think it's clear that in their
particular circumstances it is indeed
more sustainable for them to be living
there rather than anywhere else because
they would have far less need to travel
to and fro for school for work and to
their families who are their support
system therefore this application would
result in far less dependency dependency
on a car compared to them living
elsewhere this Accords with planning
policy ST1 principle of su sustainable
development secures development that
improves the economic social and
environmental conditions in the
area there are a few more discrepancies
in the report that I wish to raise you
did have already said about the Parish
Clerk um so you have already said it but
I wrote this before you did that the
report in front of you states that there
was no response received from the parish
council however if you look at the
documents uploaded to the planning
portal there is an email from the Parish
Clerk there is no formal Parish Council
in Newton St petrick but two Parish
meetings are held every year Miss
Bridgeman attended and spoke at the most
recent meeting at the end of last year
and the email from the clerk states that
the parish meeting expressed General
outline support for the application
there were no objections raised I
believe it is also worth noting that
there are no objections to the
application in general and nine
households in the local area were
concerned consulted in the hamlet where
it is proposed as well as local
residents being made aware of it at the
parish meeting so everyone's been made
aware that this application has been put
forward and there's been no objections
made at all um this Accords with
planning policy
dm1 immunity considerations it would not
significantly harm the immunities of any
neighboring occupiers or
uses another point which Miss has
already explained is regarding the bus
stop so he stated um that there's not an
official stop in Newton St Petro cross
however we know that realistically
people do use it the bus does stop there
people get on and people get off there
so the um there is a public bus Which
travels the main road 100 meters away
from the proposed dwelling it does stop
and pick up and drop off residents there
which again reflect the aspect of
sustainability policy
ST1 it seems outrageous to me that as a
council we regularly approve literally
hundreds of houses across good
agricultural Green Field Land for big
housing developers to develop on and
let's submit it quite often to a lower
standard than we would like to see and
yet we are told here to refuse a single
home for a local family to build
themselves as a council we speak about
the need to support our young people and
to help them find and live in good
quality housing and here we have a
chance to put our words into action I
understand this is only an outline
application however I do know that Mr
Davey is a highly skilled Carpenter with
an excellent reputation and I have no
doubt that the house they build together
would be of high quality and
environmentally sensitive too this
reflects the mf's economic social and
environmental objectives of a strong
responsive economy strong vibrant and
healthy communities and low carbon
economy here in front of us we have a
young couple who grew up in the area
so we'd love to stay in their home
Community surrounded by family and
friends as a council we have the
opportunity now to really have positive
impact on this family and their
Community I urge you all to please
support the application
sorry right I have no further public
speakers so I'll throw the matter open
for discussion who'd like to
keep couple of questions chair for me
page 10
um the application history relevant
history what does
fpeg stand for uh because there was an
application for two dwellings there in
fpeg sorry I should know but I don't
yeah so that wouldn't normally appear on
planning history actually that is um a
pre-application inquiry reference and I
believe the officer report does refer to
pre-application advice being sought um
and um that that response being being
negative and that was at the time that
we didn't have a fiveyear line Supply
and not encouraging um that the The
Proposal at that time was for one to two
dwellings and secondly at the bottom of
the page the uh Newton of Petro a verbal
report was that done by telephone and
somebody recorded the telephone
conversation and how would that be
recorded because there was one or two
things in there that they they requested
but we have no record here on our agenda
at the present moment yes so it was a
verbal update to the committee so what
you saw on the screen earlier is what
was written and provided by the Clark
right so so what I read out was provided
in writing I believe okay thank you for
your responsibil thank
you okay well if movie El is I'll carry
on I'll show
you yeah I just like to
uh mention or suggest that a 106 is
added for this to remain as a local um
local needs
so so the application is for an open
market dwelling that would be a
different proposal members have haven't
got the scope to introduce that
requirement at this stage and I would
also emphasize that such a local needs
dwelling would only be would only
receive policy support if the site was
was within a rural settlement which this
isn't in any
event thank you yes
gotes
thank yeah I mean just despite the
officer's recommendations and the fact
that is in open Countryside I'm sort of
minded to approve this or recommend
approval um just to point out though
that just because there is Family Care
available now that doesn't always apply
necessarily so that's the sort of
overall planning
consideration um also I think it was
mentioned that the there will be
building material materials stored there
um they're slightly concerned that there
could be some amenity problems with
noise Etc but um no doubt the planning
officers have looked at that um whether
there should be a condition on it I
don't know but um that's just a slight
concern I have thank
you um yeah so just um on that second
Point councelor hes the application does
doesn't include any proposal for any any
sort of live work element or employment
type
provision
um you know it's open to people within
their curage to to store things um but
that certainly doesn't form part of the
of the proposal um so members would have
to think about a condition and I think
in so far as supporting this application
which is essentially an open market
dwelling in the countryside which is
completely contrary to our policies we
would need a very strong material
consideration and a policy justification
for going against the established local
plan yes C wh toer thank you chair um I
was going to say I'd have been a lot
happier if it was for local needs and
that had been demonstrated but obviously
you've just told me that wouldn't have
made any difference at all I mean it
does sit within or almost within a
hamlet um and I think Council cotle hun
and did strike Accord with me that we
really ought to try and do our best to
support local families to stay within
their own areas so to speak I mean we
very often often don't or don't seem to
um it I really struggle with things like
this to be honest with you because my
heart wants to say yes we should Grant
it and my head says we might actually
give ourselves greater problems along
the lines so I'm going to just reflect
for a bit and see what my colleagues
have to say G Bush
me
has been said
about
trans we all know rural Buss are abs
horr and nearly
[Music]
everyone whatever as well as taking
children to school so
I
suggest
any other yes Council
Le thanks thanks
chair well as we all know planning
applications the starting point is our
current local plan uh which runs until
2031 the thing
is we know there are things in that
local plan we would like to change but
we can't change them just ad hoc this is
an open market dwelling or proposed open
market dwelling in the countryside
that's the definition I'm surprised it
wasn't applied for as a local needs
dwelling and a full and I said it at the
last the last meeting a full application
for an open for local needs dwelling
give you a lot more information and a
lot more be able to support if the local
need is defined I know councelor cotle
hunin spoke about the local family and
of course if you we all have sympathy
with people but I mean if we were to
Grant this today then any planning agent
out there or in here today and watching
on YouTube would be able to say all
right he is a nice bit of a field we'll
put a dwelling in there Tores will pass
that an open market dwelling and how how
do you stop that then and if you don't
approve that next one it they take it to
the planning onsman or Jud IAL review
and we're stuffed because our policy and
there's no major material issue that it
should be granted I I just wished it was
put forward as a local need because the
definition and the and the permission
granted on the local knees dwelling is
completely different to just granting
outline for an open market dwelling if
this was granted today that site could
be sold with planning permission for a
dwelling on that you know my sympathy is
with local families and people who've
got local connections to these small
areas out in the country side but we've
got to think if this was granted how do
we refuse any others I'm not talking
about being a precedent I'm talking
about our planning policies and sticking
with our planning policies unless there
are real reasons to material changes
that we accept and can can change and
without a proper application for a local
needs dwelling I don't think we can
grant those and that is the issue and
that has been the issue at many planning
meetings that we come across but you
know we've got to stick with what our
planning policies are because if we just
cast them to one side and Grant one then
planning agents out there can come in
with any little bit of field ad joining
a small settlement like this and and if
we don't approve them why do we approve
this and not another one then we really
would be on very Dodge illegal ground I
think so I'd like to see a full local
knes dwelling
application well just coming back on
your point about if this was approved
and that would open The Floodgate for
lots of other applications I mean I
always stress that each application is
on its own
merits um I just come back on a couple
of points by first comment was
disappointed that no response from the
parish council but that has been um upad
and explained
since um and the site is literally .62
of a mile from the main road and there's
properties within 10 and 30 meters of
the site there's no objection from
Neighbors the Environmental Protection
Officer subject to suitable conditions
as no objections so that Accord with
policies dmo1 and
dm2 Deon County highways have um
suggested that should the outline be
passed and full application is
submitting they have got no Highway
objections um the ecology Accord to
certain policies and I really cannot
agree with the refusal reason on page 16
where it says that one dwelling would
have an adverse visual impact on the
surrounding area I just don't see that
because it all forms part of the
Hamlet and yes I agree what counts
bushby said about the
bues um
and we've heard from the W member that
it does stop and flag down but even if
you live in town you might be a long way
from a bus stop and you might use your
car for school drop off shopping so
there's no difference in being on a bus
route um and we're always talking about
the sustainability of our town centers
but I also think it's equally important
that we sustain our rural areas because
without encouraging Young people to stay
there and send their children to school
more schools will shut so I am inclined
to support the
application thanks chair well I hear
what you say about we treat each
application on its merits of course we
do but those applications are based on
the policies we have in our local plan
and this is for this is just an outline
application we don't even know about
where it will connect to the highway off
that night there's no details at all and
it is open market and if a local needs
application to come in with an element
of of U working on the site as well
possibly a small workshop for for the
husband who has got his own carpentry
business that would be a lot better then
and we've got more meat that we can
decide on and that we're not setting
this precedent where anybody with a bit
of a field and there are plenty of sites
out there that people own bit pieces of
land how do you resist people coming in
I mean you you really are open in the
floodgates for that to happen and it is
a is I'm all for supporting local
families in local Villages and and all
that you've said but we must stick with
what our policies say as well and
without very good material reasons not
to you know I mean I don't think there's
as you read out in the reason to refuse
the actual word
I don't think it's going to blight the
countryside at all with that there but
that ain't the point actually it's the
policies that this is is not compl
comping with and I just wish the local
needs because that's what's being argued
for but this is not a local needs
application yes Captain the
back um I was going to ask um because
I'm quite new on this Committee just
temporar um so I need some guidance on
this but
um um as I sort of relate to councel
week Le Point earlier that would be a
different proposal and it's not within
the gift of the committee to be changing
a description of development at this
stage um and I would emphasize again as
I said in in the previous response that
there is no
policy position to support this
application um and equally as offices we
want to be able to support rural housing
however the starting point for you as a
committee as as with officers is our
local plan and the policies within it
the planning planning act clearly says
that to make a lawful decision your
starting point is the local plan unless
there are material considerations that
indicate otherwise and they have to be
really robust material considerations to
justify going against
our plan it's not just officers plan
it's the council's plan as as adopted
and approved by members so I I would
urge caution and I think if a
recommendation is put being put forward
for approval there would need to be very
clear policy justification and material
considerations for doing
that yes C Jes I didn't actually make a
proposal chair I I said I was minded to
approve but having listened to the
discussion
um there we are um I'm I'm not making
proposal so where does that leave coun
bushby then could you did second
that I would propose chair that we Grant
the the application but bearing in mind
we have got the state
policies I totally agree with that and
I'm not I I don't have to r on the plan
of manager to help out with uh you know
what policy we can actually uh use to
you to Grant because she's the expert on
us but you know clearly you this is it's
um although the application isn't for a
local need it is obviously for a local
family we've heard the you know the
speakers we've heard the uh the ward
member there is no objections from uh
any of the any of the neighbors and as
far as I can see it is part of that haml
yes it may be a new property that's
right on the edge of it but it's within
what 10 yard 10 m or 15 M of of the next
running and when we look at the you know
the the aerial view uh as we did earlier
I mean there's you know there's well
there's so much ground around around it
you know that one one host there all
that's going to do is is just extend
that little Hamlet just a little tiny
bit into the corner of that field and
the the corner of the field is obviously
it's got a shed there now it's got a
building there which is concealed
by all that undergrowth well you know
when it's cleared you know the footprint
that building is going to occupy isn't
going to encroach very much into that
that existing field that that the
applicant owns anyway so I can see no
reason why you know why we should be
turning it
down well I would quote perhaps it
Accords with
dm2 dmo5 DMO 6 st14 and
dm8
if had like to come back they all of
those policies relate to I would say
more sort of technical matters so
ecology parking highways you you've got
to have justification for the
fundamental principle here of an open
market dwelling in the countryside and I
think just because it's acceptable in
terms of technical matters or has the
potential to be at the detail stage of
course that would be considered at
Reserve matter stage it's justifying an
open market dwelling in this location
where there is no policy support um and
you know I I'm I'm I always try to help
the committee with conditions and
policies and I think I I would struggle
professionally to say what that policy
support could be um the plan is very
clear so then you're looking at Material
considerations that that that justify
going against policy in this case thank
you for that advice yes Council pendon
thank you chair I did have my hand up
for quite a little
while bigger I think you might be able
to see me then um situation is that I go
back to my original question about the
fpeg classification and then in 2022
people were applying for one or two
houses in the application um and I do
get the balance of of we have to have
reasons to turn it down I want to see
youngsters in the countryside I want to
see families come to the countryside but
the risk as C Le is always always
mention is there our state agents will
see the opportunity and there is nothing
to stop somebody then selling a newly
built house open market in the
countryside and having a tremendous
asset and every village has seems to
have about eight different roads running
out from it we got 64 parishes that's
500 roads and you multiply that
everything on its own Merit I accept but
I need to have some qualification of of
why we can support it and I want to
support it don't get me wrong but we've
been here before and you and I have been
in a situation where where the council's
been sued by by approving something when
it shouldn't have been approved and I
really want to make sure that I have
good SE reasons and I'm struggling to
find them at the present moment I'd like
somebody to give me something that I can
vote for it because where I am the RIS
of the other residents of torch for the
course we may incur outweigh the value
of of actually granting this application
and that's where I'm coming from chair
thank
you so we've got no well we have a
proposal our account to bushby um for
the application to be
recommended yes yes go where to go thank
you chair um is any wonder that I
couldn't really decide earlier on
exactly which side of the fence to fall
on you know and and and I say that not
likely an actual fact so I have to agree
with councelor Le but I do want to see
this young couple end up with a home
close to them their parents in the open
Countryside where they can work and
continue to live so as far as I'm
concerned the only way to achieve that
is to go back to the drawing board start
again and present us with a local need
proposal and which I would support if I
was still here thank
you do we have any F do we have a second
of for the
approval I think we all got great
sympathy with the applicants but our
hands are tied I mean I have quoted some
policies but on um the planning officers
advice they are not robust
enough um yes
Council yeah I know we're we're all torn
by these types of
applications um and the policies you
quoted chair for as you know are
development management policies there's
no as our planning manager said
principal policy that supports this
outline application for an open market
dwelling as I say it could be if it was
approved it would be so could be sold
tomorrow I'm not saying it would be I
don't think it probably would but it
could and we do open a Floodgate then
for any so I'm going to move that we
support the recommendation to refuse
chair do we have a
seconder coun
pon
we have no choice and perhaps um we
could send a message out to the
applicants you know to go back to the
drawing board is Council whitr instead
and come in with perhaps a local needs
application which we can find policies
to
support so it has been proposed by
Council Leather seconded by Council
Pennington that the application is
refused we now the vote please thank you
chair councelor
back
councilor
bushby councelor
hes phone on but if you're making a
decision in the light of the next agenda
item we should take this situation in
its own merits and not be affected by
the next agenda item and I just think
there might be a risk for us here if we
are affected by what comes up next and
not consider this in its own right no
it's a completely separate application
the next
item
right okay um councelor Le four
councelor lock four councelor Pennington
four councelor Thomas four councelor W
weatley councelor
whiter thank
you so seven for chair one against and
one exstension thank very
much right application C on your agenda
is application number 1 Str 0838 part
retrospective and all weather turnout at
Northern and it's on pages 18 to 36 of
your agenda are there any Declarations
of
Interest
jeel hated but not on Northern Town
council's
Comm
thank you chair hope everyone can hear
me okay so I'm the case officer my name
is Ryan steppel and I'm presenting the
case for uh as Council lock has referred
to the part retrospective application
for an all weather
turnout
next
um just before we start there's a few
updates so uh members who are at the
site visits will remember that um uh the
relationship between potential Heritage
assets nearby just to let members know
an enforcement has been served in
respect to the works to the banker and
I'll just progress
on in terms of this this update we've
got here I think members asked a few
questions rightly so um and members will
recall as some queries certainly to do
with surface finish uh whether it would
be private or um public use and how the
how the and how the uh turnout will be
used so I could just read off this slide
so the surface finish of the area will
be sand and fiber so the appearance will
be granular sand with some short fibers
in it the use is predominantly as an all
weather turnout area for hallion young
stop and Broad mes it is likely to be
used at times for breaking and training
of young young horses as as it is at a
safe and fenced area which will include
riding its more regular use will be as a
turnout area it use will be in highly
private for Miss jobson Scott and her
horses with no commercial
letting next
pleas so members will remember some of
these slides so I'll um progress through
as as quickly as I can so we have uh
this is the application site as you can
see it's to the north of aquador Road
got Northern B to the north and sort of
areas of Northern to the South next
slide and this is just a sort of
close-up image so we've got uh the sort
of yellow Square to the sort of uh
middle right of this image reflects
where the turnout is to be located
you've got the access to the South and
then Northern bis to the
north and this is the sort of superseded
location plan so we have the superseded
location plan on the left and on the
right is an image which U shows where
the red Edge s um used to pass through
um the listing associated with the
bunker next slide
please and therefore the red Edge was
therefore amended and the application
was restarted um and all and a complete
reconsultation
next and what we have here is a proposed
site plan so just for context you've got
the access to the South the turnout is
um 46 M by 35 M and as you can see
you've got if we go to the next slide
Helen you can see the proposed sort of
Earth Bank on that sort of western side
where the sort of Frontage bit uh next
slide
please and we have a section drawing
which just sort of indicates the sort of
fencing and potential um Earth Bank
treatments this is a map of the extent
of the undeveloped Coast which relates
to a policy in our local plan aiming to
protect the uh tranquil and Coastal
character of certain locations locations
within the undeveloped Coast uh I've
sort of put a star where approximately
where the site is located and you can
sort of see that sort of black line
around Northern sort of indicates where
the development boundary f finishes I
think we've got a closer image of the
site in relationship to the development
boundary on the next
slide and as you can see we've got
Northern biston North and sort of the
site and its proximity to the
development
boundary this is an image which shows
the site in it in context so if you look
on this slide you can sort of see that
sort of Red Square which sort of
indicates the location of the turnout
and then these are sort of surrounding
Heritage assets in in in close
proximity
uh and this is a a slide which shows the
access for the
site in the next two slides I think are
helpful in my view to sort of show some
of the landscape qualities around the
site obviously in my report I've sort of
talked about
um the nature of the undeveloped coast
and what this policy aims to protect the
sort of tranquil nature of this
landscape I think it's quite important
even though you've got that policy
protection in terms of policy s29 so
actually look at this landscape in on
its own merits as sort of council Locker
sort of referred to to look at
applications on own merits what we have
here and in the next slide but I'll get
to that in a second I just thought I'd
talk about some of these qualities which
I think are quite apparent so this this
is the view from appledore road so as
you can see the sort of lighter green
bit in the sort of distance is Northern
Burrows there's the actual site is
actually quite open you know locally
we're quite used to having quite field
boundaries and like tight Parcels of
Fields but here it's really open I think
that heightens that sense of coastal
character and that sense of openness
that you that you get from being in in
this location and the next slide
Helen and again just another image this
could be on a postcard I guess but sort
of just right across this landscape
where you can sort of see the only
real impact is caused by quite low
impact fencing which doesn't really
cause a sort of adverse character impact
in my view and um and in relation to
this sort of view across this landscape
I think what we're looking at here is
we're looking at you know the fact that
there's been
no adversely harmful changes of use the
the the the land and in its character
sort of remained relatively sort of
agricultural grazing and um the land is
relatively free from obstruction except
for those Heritage assets which sort
surround the application
site
and this is a picture of the uh turnout
so what we're looking we're looking from
sort of west to east here so this is
where you'll see that sort of Earth
bonding proposed on the right hand side
of this image at the front at the moment
obviously the site is excavated so once
it's finished it will raise up to sort
of ground
level and uh and this is just again of
that sort of s so we've got the southern
boundary of the T out um and then the
sort of easn bound in the distance next
please
tell and this is taken from within the
turnout itself looking South towards a
Heritage asset which is located just on
the other side of this boundary
treatment and this is a view from the
turnout and then sort of looking again
giving you those sort of reflections of
you know the undeveloped Coast that open
us looking towards Northern barrows in
the distance and those Heritage asset
which are in image
here and this is sort of looking the
opposing Direction back towards
appledore Road as you can sort of see
the dwellings in the in the distance
there at the top you see the bunker and
and and an existing
Caravan and members will be aware um of
this application which went to appeal
and that appeal decision is within your
agenda um so I thought I'd just again
for repetition uh provide these slides
which you may have already seen seen so
this is the this was the application for
the building and then we have um forget
the next slide uh the refusal reasons
that it was refused
upon next hello and the sort of um the
sort of reasons in the inspector's
decision that as again we've we sort of
spoke about
so so what we have here are the main
considerations now you
yeah I just wondering why Ryan is
talking about an application that's
already been refused we're not
considering a b we're considering the
turn area surely I I appreciate that
it's more for context I don't know if
members wanted to see the drawings
essentially that's fine if you don't but
you know they're they're more for
context I was going to make the same
point later on
okay
uh so we go back to the um the main
consideration so in terms as we've
already heard you know the starting
point is a local plan and the policies
in within the local plan obviously we'll
run through the main
considerations the four reasons are
contained within your report as as you
can sort of see but in terms of
principal development it aims to support
development where it does not detract
from the character of the undeveloped
coast and principally it is required
because it cannot be reasonably located
outside the undeveloped
Coast the justification provided is not
considered sufficient uh to justify the
location or use proposed and therefore
is considered to be conflict with those
policies um in respect to character and
Landscape the site and its wider
surroundings are prominent to
uninterrupted views towards the
coastline and the land and wer land in
my in my view essentially has been used
in quite a low impact way and such a way
that with respect to landscape it's
remained um relatively uninterrupted for
many
okay and it's remained relatively wild
and tranquil with no development or
change of use having taken place
therefore in my view the provision of a
turnout would result in adverse visual
intrusion upon this landscape and
therefore not be supported by our
policies with with in relation to the
undeveloped Coast in terms of her
matters and I think the chair is aware
of this but we have um Mr Reed from um
the historic environment team at D
County Council and I would advise
hearing from him today however I will
just touch upon what I feel are the main
points that I've raised in my
report the application as you know
shares a close relationship with various
Heritage assets associated with the RAF
Northern chain home station the extent
of this impact is discussed within my Au
report however focus on two main points
firstly that the application is
supported by insufficient Heritage
assessment to conclude what the impact
and significance of those Heritage
assets secondly and I think this is a
point I would stress to members your
officers have essentially and I include
the conservation officer and also um the
Devon County environment officer have
concluded that the proposal results in
less than substantial harm at the upper
end on these Heritage assets the
framework says that where this is the
case the application must demonstrate a
public benefit to offset that harm and
no no public harm exist no public
benefit exists here in your office's
opinion therefore um therefore the I
would recommend refus on that reason uh
regarding immunity highways drainage and
ecology there are no substantive
concerns thank you for listening to me
and um if you've got any questions
please ask to you ch
I now go to the public speaker this our
first registered speaker is Sally jobson
Scott if you'd like to come to the front
thank
you could you
yeah yeah you have three minutes okay
thank you good morning counselors my
name is Sally jobson Scott I hope you
receive my email explaining in detail I
kept Folly foot riding school trkking
Center open which has now caused me
significant problems I put this
successful local business first and now
I require facilities for my break my
breeding stock I could have easily
closed the riding school and stayed at
fifoot as it had all my facilities I
needed but that's not me my hundreds of
clients who I taught personally and had
built up over the years children and
adults many many had physical and
learning disabilities and mental health
conditions I loved teaching them all and
every one of them meant a lot to me and
I couldn't let them down by closing the
riding school so now I need help with my
planning application for an all weather
turnout this is not as the conservation
officer said a new equestrian business
I've been commercially breeding and
training Folly foot show jumpers for
over 40 years using these fields for
grazing and exercising my horses and the
war bunker for stabling since I just the
Freehold in
1994 during this time I've bred over 30
horses at this land during the last few
years we've had so much rain sometimes
one month's rainfall in one day this
makes the land water logged and boggy
using these fields for grazing when they
are water loged causes long-term damage
to the soil structure and plant
biodiversity the all weather turnout
will enable me to provide turnout for my
breeding stock to exercise which is
essential for their Health and Welfare
the reason I chose this area for the
work for the all weather turnout are the
land is already flat and drains into my
Lake the land was very low grazing value
there are mature Hedges and trees
surrounding three edges the all weather
turnout is not visible from the Burrows
nor from Apple Door Road there will be
not any significant harm to either of
the listed War bunkers as they are a
long distance from the all weather
turnout the land is far enough away from
the main fif foot riding school to
provide biocurity for my worldclass
brooded mares and FES keeping them safe
from diseases which could cause
fatalities to my infall May's embryos or
to Young FES the all weather turnout
will enhance my 12 acres of CPA land
providing a biodiversity net
gain BNG is an approach to development
and or Land Management that aims to
leave the natural environment in a
measurably better State than it was
beforehand it will enable me to keep the
horses off the wet boggy fields for
sometimes up to seven months of the year
this will allow the grasses flowers
floor and fora to flourish creating a
rich natural habitat for the Wildlife
attracting much needed bees and insects
back to the area and becoming a valuable
asset for the natural environment and
Wildlife Conservation also by planting
new Hedges and trees we enhance the land
providing Wildlife corridors and new
natural habitats for the birds and
mammals there will be no actual change
of use of my land as my horses have
exercised and grazed this field where
it's be cited since 1994 can I ask you
to wind up please the only difference is
it will have an all weather surface
instead of a wet boggy field in the wet
weather thank you thank you very
much and next register speaker is
Rebecca
Fernley good morning members um so I'm
speaking in support of the application
as agent for the application I do want
to just clarify a point which I feel is
an error in the officer's report which
says that the proposed surfacing and
finish in of the um of the all weather
turnout is going to be brought back up
to ground level that's not correct the
actual area has been excavated in order
to level the area and the surface will
be applied to the level now so it will
remain below what was the existing
ground level and I think that's quite an
important consideration because of where
it's located um sort of enclosed by
three natural hedge rows um and actually
a location that when we discussed with
County archaeology and Steven Reed the
was felt to be the most least impactful
um location on the site actually when we
were looking at the possible stable site
um sighting which we referred to
previously so I think that's quite an
important Point um I also want to say
the clients's own the site since 1994
and established her equestrian business
there can be no debate that this land is
in equestrian use it was referred to
again in the um officer report that it
was in agricultural use but it's
actually in established equestrian use
in addition to this if we actually look
at the land and the land between
Westwood ho and Well sandir Road and
Watertown what is clear is a lot of this
land is actually in equestrian use
there's quite a few small Livery yards
um and private turnouts so there's quite
a lot of equestrian related development
in that area already there's stable
blocks there's small barns small sheds
um because the area isn't really big
enough to be used an intensive
agricultural use because you've got the
housing of sort of appledore and
Northern behind it so I feel that that's
quite an important Point as well that
that is already established the other
point I want to make is that we're not
proposing a new access this is already
established and we're not proposing any
Works close to the listed building um
there's no built structure proposed um
and what we're looking at is some
specified engineering work so excavation
some banks fencing and surfacing of the
area
um I think it's been there's been a lot
of justification of the application
letters from vets about the BIOS
security and Sally's breeding program um
and also I think the fact that she has
maintained and focused on keeping Folly
foot riding school open but allowing
herself some facilities to continue her
important breeding program you know
she's got some nationally and
internationally successful show jumpers
and if you're not interested in horses
then that might not be that exciting but
actually for someone to achieve that
locally in the local economy is really
important and the fact that she
selflessly um moved her operation rather
than using her own facilities in order
to be able to keep the riding school
open um I think also when she bought the
land the bunkers weren't listed I you to
war up you've had three minutes okay the
bunkers weren't listed and I think
that's quite significant because they
were listed in 2015 so it's not like she
bought something with these known listed
buildings and to be clear again we are
some distance from any of the listed
assets so I'd ask members to support
this application thank you thank
you and last ready speaker is the ward
member Council F please thank you um
thanks chair for this opportunity you'll
be glad to know and like most of that
would all that my voice has been playing
up so a lot of people not very happy and
no doubt some of these fellow counselors
will be but I'll keep therefore very
brief um don't want to give it a history
lesson but I have obviously as you
probably aware of been there all my life
and actually I can remember the being a
football pitch on it for a couple years
and I don't think we would really want
22 people kicking the ball and swearing
I used to be one of them
so I'm trying to make this joval but
it's very important that one person here
today that what she does know about
horses isn't worth worrying about and
I'm going to keep this very brief I
personally haven't got an objection
isn't about just me it's about the
greater area Natural England hasn't got
an objection I don't see any from local
residents L Town Council is basically
behind it so again I repeat on balance
and I accept this always for good
governance I say you got to be open
transparent fair not biased on balance I
can't see a good reason to refuse
I would also like to add I've known
Sally for a long time and probably one
of her failin just like me she probably
got a big Gob on occasion but I think
she's honest she has don't have to I
mean recently I'd like to congratulate
her in the local press about the success
she had at National level so we're not
talking about little sheing STM X pck
ponies so nice as they are this is a
woman that takes this damn serious and I
hope we come to the right judgment
because we got a lot lot of power in
ours affecting one human being don't
forget that thank you Council
for that's the end of the register
speakers but as um our planet manager
said we do have the senior historic
environmental officer from De County
Council um I don't know if Mr stepen
Reed yeah so I don't know if any members
have got any questions for
him yes C
pendon can I get the picture I
read the portal last night all the
comments um after I had a meeting here
last night so I didn't go to bed till
1:00 so I apologize I do fall asleep
later on um let me get my photograph up
here of your comments sir because I
let's get the last one
here sorry to keep the chair I've just
got to get to the
correct record that I made last
night that you can't see on the report
but it does
say that there should have been a survey
done and you refer the client to the
charges and costs
involved yes and that's the very last
paragraph I can't find it here now
actually did quote I did photograph it
last night oh here have I got it
here yes I mean that um no okay yeah but
but I'm just concerned that there is a a
you've got an interest here that that is
going to
cost the applicant money Devon County
Council will charge the applicant to get
a further survey to done and what always
worries me with any of development in
these days time you get ecological
archaological etc etc it becomes
unviable for any any business to run
eventually and I just wondered if it
should be separated the the the uh or
the DCC survey and actually then
suggesting we will send you the cost of
doing that survey okay that that that's
a standard part of our response um to
applicants when we to to to flag up that
we the historic environment team charge
for Our advice when we get involved in
the planning application in proving
project designs monitoring all that sort
of thing
um what we have
said to the applicant is that because I
don't know is it possible to get slide
13 up just if to to sort as background
for for our
concerns
um so we've got this um this map shows
um the area with the uh turnout and all
of the listed buildings around it so
what we're looking at here is an early
1940s radar station um that was designed
to look at um detect highflying bombers
going to Bristol out into the Atlantic
up to Cardiff and Swansea to the
industrial centers at the beginning of
the wall and maybe up to um uh
Birmingham as well uh and possibly um
intercepting planes and Ships coming in
from the Bristol channel so what we're
looking at is a landscape with some
World War II Heritage in some really
really
significant archaeology and Heritage
built environment um so we' got the
bunkers we got the Earth traverses we've
got the sites of the radar uh M all the
WR all the uh the anchors and everything
else um in
2015 the um the site was listed by
historic England because it represents a
really good example of of surviving
World War II radar station um its
significance is because it survives in a
readable form you can look at the site
you can understand what went on there uh
it's significant because it's associated
with one of the most um significant
events of the first of the 20th century
um it represents Britain's technological
Advance uh advantage over the Nazis at
that time to allow us to stay in the war
despite numerical and Military um uh the
Nazis being more dominant in those
factors um and so what we our concerns
are is if you are um while this
development am I timed sorry I'm not
being
timed no your time I think it's just to
provide that that context for I think
you're there for questions really not to
give us a whole briefing because we've
got the briefing in our report so I
think you're just there to answer
questions with all due respect sorry
sorry has anyone got any questions yes
can
wh go back to that picture again if I
may the application the Orange is the uh
second world war sites yes and the red
is the application site yes is there any
orange within the application boundary
please no but what the reason why I was
explaining why what the nature of the
site is we're looking at a landscape
military World War II military landscape
and so you're having development within
there that affects the setting of all
those monuments Our Heritage doesn't
exist in isolation as humps and bumps or
sites under the ground they exist in a
landscape they relate to other things
all of those
blobs on there relate to each other so
if by putting a development in between
them you're having an impact on the
setting you're changing the character of
the landscape around them you're
changing the color of the ground by
putting in um you know whatever the
surface is for the turnout you're
putting introducing I mean you can see
the excavations are quite substantial so
they're generating a lot of soil you're
so you're then putting in buns new hedge
Banks um you're changing the level of
the ground you're putting in fencing um
all those sort of things are changing
the setting of this nationally important
Heritage asset that is here my continue
chair I'm sorry it takes so long but it
is really important I feel here at the
moment because if you go onto the
barrels on the water tone
entrance just as you go over the bridge
there is the the concrete stanions for
the radar MH poles now what concerns me
is that this area of land here is is not
on the Burrows it is a different color
green it's different type of ground and
there's a lot of uh equestrian stuff
along that way and I'm really worried
that you're going to hamper our economy
if you link all these little red spots
that's going to go all the way from here
which is
by by the Sandy Mir entrance all the way
to the water tone entrance and I I I
think you're you're you're given a real
concern for businesses within that area
well what what was saying is really is
is not we're not saying no at this stage
is what we're saying is that the the
applicant has not supplied enough
information to allow the the
significance or the importance of the
Heritage our heritage tor's heritage the
significance of that and what is going
to be the impact of the development
within that area um that that is one of
our reasons for you know one of our
reasons for recommending refusal because
of the lack of that sort of information
I mean if you if you could imagine if
this safe for example was an Elizabethan
you know planned Garden or Park a
registered Park and garden it's a sort
of information a planning application
would need to be supported by and just
because this is World War II archaeology
I wouldn't say that the significance is
less that means you don't need to
actually consider the impact on the the
setting of of Heritage thank you for
indulging me chair Captain
wio
thank thank you not personally I have to
say it might happen I just want to ask
you quite a simple question and I
suppose I could have left it in a way
but it is quite relevant um the
applicant bought this land and 21 years
later it got
listed what what happened then did you
did you or somebody like you come and
say to her hang on a minute now
everything changed for you you can't do
this or you can't do that no no it's not
that really concerns me no no no list um
we are discovering things all the time
so that the fact that things aren't
protected or scheduled or listed now
doesn't mean that they won't be
protected or listed in the future I
don't know the reasons what triggered
listing in
2015 um but at that time it was
considered that these were s the site
was of such significance and it needed
protecting from future damage listing
doesn't necess doesn't necessarily mean
no development but it means the
development needs to be appropriate and
without understanding the impact of your
development you can't put forward any
mitigation for mitigating that
impact can I come back to but as I
understand it the applicant had already
been using one part of that listing for
her own needs what the other bunker the
other well the applicant had actually um
a few years ago taken the the Earth M
off country because she didn't know she
did oh she did she did um we have I've
got um copies of letters from Mr England
to the applicant and I've got a email
response from the applicant in 2015 so
she did know it was listed um the other
points that were raised by the agent
were that saying the development is not
close to a listed building it is close
to a listed building it's 13 MERS away
from the uh Transformer block um you
can't see it anymore um and our advice
to use our advice um which we gave about
putting a stable in this landscape um
and using that as a justification but
this larger development I think is um a
bit unfair in that there's a difference
between putting a stable block tucking
it in against a hedge in the corner of a
field compared to a large um excavation
and turnout creation of a turnout area
fencing the landscape and building um
buns and and hedge banks in this
landscape Chang continue because there's
one more thing I want to get clarified
yeah okay I'm really local Heritage
anybody who knows me would know that
right so I can understand the importance
of the whole site right and and your
wish to preserve it no no does it get a
lot of visitors is it advertised do
people know about it and I'm not saying
it isn't important but I think it's
relevant
today it it's
sorry it's it's not it's not about
preserving it in in aspect it's about
the the development being appropriate
local and National planning policy talks
about preserving and enhancing our Our
Heritage and the fact it's in private
land and no one can get to see it is
academic because most listed buildings
most archaeological sites most scheduled
monuments are in private ownership and
the fact that they are currently in
private ownership does not mean does not
devalue their worth as Heritage assets
the thing is with our heritage assets is
that once they're gone they they they're
gone and if don't uh you know uh act
they they
disappear right there's no V yes
cly thank
you thank you
chair
RAF what RAF I've never heard that
expression until I actually read this
document I have heard of the chain home
um comments uh before and obviously I've
seen the you know the the concrete
structures that litter the uh the
Burrows and the surrounding area I say
litter because a few years ago you know
most people in the right mind would have
got a a swing shot and demolished them
because you know they they serve no
useful purpose unless you're actually
using the building for a for a store so
it's only been listed in 2015 it's only
nine years ago so you know from 1945 at
the end of the war until 2015 they were
unimportant to anyone so you know that's
just a comment but you know the the fact
that can bush is this a direct question
well or you just gone on to the
discussion I've gone on to
the I I can't really see the the
significance of the objections all of
these structures are made of reinforced
concrete no one's proposing to demolish
them or take them away or anything like
that and I for the life of me I can't
see how having a turnout area which is
you know a low-lying
um area covered in sand is going to is
going to affect or hurt that you know
that that that concrete structure I just
I I just don't get
that the questions then thank you for
your input Mr re thank you very much
okay and I will now open the matter up
for discussion who'd like yes counc I I
could just continue sh the you know the
site is is next to Northern B which is
Tri
SII Natural England have got no
objection
aom team no response received so I take
it from that there is no objection
environment agency have got no response
I take that as no objections as well
Devon County Council standing advice so
is no objection uh and the Environmental
Protection Officer has no objection to
the proposed development number of
neighbors consulted 23 number of
objection letters zero Northern Town
Council are in agreement that it should
be it should be
approved why on Earth have we
recommended
refusal I would I would recommend that
we approve this uh that we Grant this
application but you must quote some
policies I well I'm I'm coming on to
that in a minute but
right so is the proposal any further
comments yes coun well thank you
um Council bushby has done done some of
my work for me thank you very much but
there's a couple things I want to say
and there was something about the
wildness and the aspect looking from the
road over the Burrows but an actual fact
already there's a great deal of natural
foliage around the site where the
turnout is going to be so to some degree
that's already been sorted another thing
I want to say is because I've kept
horses most of my life actually having a
turnout where you can take horses
especially very valuable horses but
actually at the bottom line is all
horses if you look after your horses
properly and you you need to take them
out of the mud and you're poaching your
ground beyond belief to be honest with
you so there are two reasons that why
that should happen and and an actual
fact if the applicant is sharing
accommodation with the Stables which she
sold at the moment that is probably more
risky for the well-being of the animals
than a lot of people would realize um I
also think that and because that would
be important for the Stables as well
which is a a good viable business which
I hope will remain so in perpetuity so I
think there's an awful lot of things
that you need to think about when you
when you when you're considering refusal
and I actually wouldn't consider refusal
I would consider Grant thank
you plan off come back a moment is that
okay yeah thank you thank you shair so I
think I'll just come back on a few
issues um allowing sort of discussion
and understand members obviously this is
quite important application um so
firstly it's been mentioned about how
the land is pre-existing it's
pre-existing use essentially uh there is
no history of a Planning Commission or
consent which relates to equestrian use
the land has essentially been used as
grazing land which our definition of
agriculture it would fall within that
definition of agriculture so I think
it's about making that distinction at
this point I think it's also worth
mentioning that you know the council has
policies which relates to equin
development and then also development in
the developed Coast I think some Fair
points councelor whiter but are talking
about that landscape consideration it's
also worth mentioning that policy sd9
which relates the undeveloped Coast
almost looks at okay what is the
landscape
consideration and and it might be that
members decide you know the landscape
impact is quite low but it also
recognized the value of the undeveloped
coast and and that's why it's been
designated So within our local plan so
in in essence what that policy requires
is why can it not be outside the
undeveloped Coast in in simple terms and
previous appeals and you'll see in my
report uh we've had appeals this week uh
as well and they talk about the
undeveloped Coast being this sort of
finite resource essentially once it's
diluted it's it's it's gone so it's
there has to be a justification put
forward to demonstrate why here
essentially um and then I think it's
just worth mentioning and re
reemphasizing the points that um Mr Reed
has made essentially that it's about the
setting of this historic landscape and
the impact of this development upon that
historic setting and that's all I'll say
for
now yes
counes thank you chair um yeah there's
been quite a lot of talk about policies
at this meeting and yet I don't know it
seems as though policies being suggested
we should not take any notice of in this
application um the planning officer is
sorry no no speak oh the planning
officer has set out very clearly it's in
the undeveloped Coast um it's also in um
an area which is subject to the revised
joint local landscape character
assessment um which has uh only just
been revised last year I think and that
includes for this particular area
Coastal undulating Farmland wide
uninterrupted sea views evoke a strong
sense of openness openness working
agricultural landscape rolling Farmland
rural character important Coastal
habitats peaceful and tranquil qualities
um this applies to this area um it's
also as I understand it in a strategic
nature area though I may be corrected on
that one um the planning agent when she
gave her um statement to this
meeting uh referred to surrounding areas
where horses are kept um but what we're
that's fine that's in on grass grazing
but we're being um it's been applied to
us that that this should be an area
large area of hard surface well that
would significantly impinge in my view
on on the landscape and the undeveloped
Coast um in terms of the archaeology U
sorry I was go back a bit um councelor
bushby has said that on the various
consules have had no objection but that
rather ignores the fact that we've had
extremely strong comments from the uh
conservation officer for this Council um
it's quite rare in my view that such a
strong comment is put forward we've also
heard from the county archaeologist
again a strong comment and um
recommending refusal until the required
reports are submitted again this is part
of policy the um reports on the
significance and setting the impact on
um listed buildings um a full full
survey and Report should be presented so
again that's very strong comment um in
terms of I'm concerned in terms of
wildlife um the planning agent said that
um no I'm sorry I think sad Mrs jobson
Scott said that it's better for wildlife
if there's a hard surface area um I may
be wrong but
my I think that it um in terms of horses
grazing trampling is quite a good thing
for wildlife it actually spreads seeds
it's actually increas possibly increases
biodiversity um and I'm so I'm slightly
doubtful about the claim that there's
going to be a net gain um and also I'm
slightly concerned um about about the
effect of this area on the
surrounding what is usually um called in
a derogatory way scrub in fact that
surrounding area around the trampling
site is extremely important habitat um
for small birds butterflies all sorts of
things but I am slightly concerned that
this area would impinge badly on wild
life um to
conclude um the applicant
um the applicant has applied and stated
that there this will be purely for
private use um so in terms of justifying
it on undeveloped Coast I can't see huge
public benefit basically um I may be a
bit naive but why could the site have
been put sort of nearer to the
development which is down on Sandy Road
where the Stables are while why does it
have to go out in the open Countryside
and imped impinge on in such a way um so
there are my comments
chair Depend and you're
next very briefly dm16 equine
development is what I would quote is the
reason um to uh Grant the application
permission and I would second counc
buri's
proposal I use the
M16 aqu development councelor Whitaker
thank you I just wanted to reassure
councelor haes actually because if you
turn a lot of horses out during the
winter months and you poach the land so
they can no longer graze on
it you've got to put the horses
somewhere for their own well-being and
in actual fact you're not doing the land
any favors either at the end of the day
you're taking away something from the
land and you're taking away something
from the horses in real terms just
thought I wanted to mention that counc
Thomas
just just a brief observation um the
applicant referred to needing the space
for this um because she's uh sold the
previous business I mean surely that's a
commercial decision and I'm not quite
sure why that's really
material to to the current
application does the plan of wish to
come back on that yeah I think it's fair
point
that's it is it right thank
good um yeah from my point of view I
mean I do agree with Council bushby I
mean Northern Town Council support
there's no objections from Natural
England and I cannot believe that we've
received no response of the a aom if
it's such an important area of land I
read um in great detail our conservation
officers
report um and it is I I will quote
um there's all uh states that the
introduction of fencing in this area and
the uncovering of the listed type c
receiver block have already altered
views across the Burrows and Beyond
neither is it help by the storage of a
caravan horse boox and assorted domestic
items this level of harm is considered
to be less than substantial but with the
creation of a new equ estan business on
the site would make this the higher
level of less than
substantial now I would therefore read
this is is still been less than
substantial so I it has been said so I
mean we yes I haven't quite finished it
so I mean I would um I'm like I would
like to approve the
application and quote dmo1 dm8 and S
T14 in addition to the um one that
councilor Pennington quoted yeah yes
Council
Le thanks chair well talk about over
egging the pudding on this Heritage
aspects this application is on the site
of established equine use of many years
and the only issue for consideration
really is whether the turnout area
proposed has the detrimental impact on
the listed World War II bunker that is
what we're looking at that is the nub of
it um we've all heard it's been in the
ownership of the applicant for many
years since 1994 I think we've heard
that um there's no objection to Natural
England environment agency or tdcs
Environmental Protection and there's no
com up from historic England and the a
which surprises me when consider
considering the Heritage asset
situation and the gentleman from Devon
County Council spoke
about proving the effect well you can
see from the application what the
possible effect would be on the bunker
on the concrete bunker you can see that
because here is a plan of what's
proposed we've had aerial pictures of it
we've so we know exactly what where it
is
what if any effect there is on the
bunker and we I think from listening to
colleagues I don't think anybody thinks
has any effect on the bunker from this
development it will be improved with a
drop curb to be put at the access onto
app Door Road so you know I've got a
list of policies here it complies with I
think most of the policies quoted I mean
quality of dis de of development I
mean there's nothing being developed
only this you know I mean there's so
many policies quoted apart from the
equant ones not even mentioned in the
report
so I think it complies with most of and
certainly uh
st9 uh bracket
s it complies with that so which is the
uh coast and EST strategy so you know I
just don't know and then we had all this
beforeand of previous application that
been you know and then bringing somebody
up from the County Council to it seems
It's really over egged to put it on
which is something straightforward and I
don't know why it's been done like that
and and it irritates me nowh
that sure right on on that note um sure
yeah sorry Council yeah well councelor
leather's got his own views I mean just
because he has strong opinions it
doesn't mean other people don't don't
and that's why the County Council and
the consummation officer have made their
statements so you know they just Happ to
disagree with you these are strong
supposedly strategic policies are
supposed to govern this site and protect
the landscape and the Vista so you know
I think that's very important if if it
does sorry if it does come to a
recommendation uh for approval then I
may I ask there's a condition that
there's no public use on the side
please
yes councel just come back quickly then
I'm going to go to the planning office
i' also written down that in the report
it speaks about private use and no
public benefit well I would beg to
differ with that because the success for
me anyway and I think probably for
colleagues here of any local business
and this is a business that's working on
here in the breeding of these very
valuable and very renowned horses for
show jumping events
increasing uh International reputation
has a a beneficial knock on effect for
the local area and for local businesses
anything that we can help businesses
succeed in the area we should be doing
so the Heritage aspect that and
councelor hes Bang the Drum for that I
know when we had that debate at the plan
last planning application on the key
here about the canopy on the cafe there
there have you got Heritage assets there
that row of cottages in a conservation
area we didn't get anybody up from the
County Council to to talk so I just
think you know it really has over him I
just like to I think our planning
manager can perhaps see the way that the
discussion's going and I just like her
to confirm What policies we could
use okay so I mean the the starting
point with any recommendation and to
have a sort of lawful sound basis is
obviously to cite policies um and if
that recommendation is then moveed
forward to a vote there also need to be
conditions which which the case officer
will deal with um lots of different
policies have been raised here I think
Council leather's most recent comment
around public benefit is really
important harm has been identified here
in Heritage terms um the reason Mr Reed
didn't come up in respect to the the
canopy is that was a listed building
matter Mr Reed is more focused on
archaeology so um and the nature of this
historic landscape so it is wholly
relevant that he is here it is an
important issue paragraph 208 of the
mppf is engaged in so far as less than
substantial harm has been identified
here and there is therefore a need to
weigh that against public benefits so I
I think councelor Lether has
articulated what he considers to be
public benefit as a rule we wouldn't
consider a sort of Private Business
interest to be a public benefit but I
appreciate Council Le has articulated
something that maybe follows on from
that but that's a really important point
that has to be considered in any
recommendation for approval recognizing
par 208 of the mppf um it's all set out
in the case officers report report and
that conflict with our heritage policies
it is about setting here it's not about
being right next to a particular
concrete structure it is the wider
setting of this historic landscape and
the impact that this all weather turnout
will have equally policy
st9 the undeveloped Coast is a is a
really important strategic allocation
it's a strategic policy and there are
some very clear tests that are are
slightly different to simply looking at
landscape harm it has to be proven and
accepted that this this particular
development could not be located
anywhere else to be acceptable under
st9 um and there also are tests of
Tranquility open character and you know
the appeal decision appended describes
an open and wild landscape and I think I
would also emphasize as pointed out by
the case officer in planning terms this
is considered to be agricultural land
not equestrian land um but all of that
pulled together in the points that I've
heard I think dm16 was also cited um it
it doesn't explicitly comply with that
um
it is an a it is a horse related
facility in the countryside so this does
give support um it does talk about new
ancillary development being well related
to existing buildings I appreciate
that's slightly different here um but I
think if members are minded um it would
be to to confirm that dm16 and
st7 um allow for this equestrian use in
this location and also the
st9 um you need to be satisfied that it
can't be located anywhere else and that
there isn't that harm to tranquility and
open character and also in terms of mppf
par 208 that the benefits the public
benefits of this proposal outweigh the
less than substantial harm so I think
all of these things have been mentioned
but I think they all need to be sort of
tied together in that recommendation I
think some of the policies that have
been raised are more DM technical
policies but your fundamental principle
policies I would say are st9 st7 DM 16
is then enabled beneath those policies
and also that balance through mppf par
208 in terms of the public benefit
outweighing the harm so I think there
has been discussion around all of those
but that that's what I would Direct in
terms of being cited in in a reason to
to move approval yes C push you have to
come
back
so are you happy with those you seconded
the proposal Council Penington I am
seconding second in the brsh beond that
additional comment yeah can I just pick
on the ml9 which our planning manager
stress I always find difficulty with
this one because it says on um Clause a
alternative Greener structure is
provided at least equivalent size
quality and accessibility to that being
lost that means we can never develop
anything that's a differ that's a
different policy councelor Pennington
st9 st9 yeah which which is which is a
strategic policy and includes a
reference to the undeveloped
Coast come back allocates that so
um we did have another proposal from
Council hes that the application is
refused did we have a seconder for
that no second
right yes Council check
C can we uh because Heritage has been
made such a thing of on this
application uh the
mppf uh where it talks about Heritage
aspects and at 202 on page well in mi it
says where develop and it's been
accepted where development proposal will
lead to less than substantial harm which
has been established here to the
significance of a designated Heritage
asset this harm should be weighed
against the public benefits which the
planning officer mentioned of The
Proposal but he stopped at that but it
goes on to say including where
appropriate securing its Optimum viable
use now we're not talking about the use
of the Heritage asset at all but I just
think somewhere we ought to be quoting
from Heritage
assets the mppf which does
support development I mean
mean as I said to bring somebody up from
from
exitor to go into all this just you've
made that point once or twice councelor
and I'm sure we've taken it all on
board I I think planning manager wants
to come
back hi hi counselor thank you for that
um just in terms of that Optimum viable
use which is contained within that um
that 208 parag gra uh there's actually
guidance in the mppg which talks about
what Optimum viable use so I'll just
read it out if that's helpful so it says
the vast majority of Heritage assets are
in private hands thus sustaining
Heritage Assets in the long term often
requires an incentive for their
conservation putting Heritage assets to
viable uses likely to lead in investment
by their nature some Heritage assets
have limited or even no economic end use
the scheduled monument in a rural area
May preclude use of land um it is more
important that any use is viable not
just for the owner but also the future
conservation of the asset if there
is uh if there is a range of
alternatively economic viable uses
Optimum viable use is the one that is
likely to cause the least harm to the
significance of the asset not just
through necessary initial changes but
also as a result of subsequent wear and
tear and any future changes the optimum
viable use may not be the most economic
viable one nor it need be the original
use however from conservation point of
view there's no diff different real
between alternatively uh economic viable
use then a choice of uses a decision for
the owner subject to of course obtain
obtaining relevant consern thank
you so I I think Council bushby has
obviously mooved for approval it it
sounds like members of that view
consider par 208 that the public
benefits out way the identified harm um
and in terms of st9 the discussion
has suggested in terms of that
recommendation to move to approval that
the the landscape harm is not such the
harm to tranquility and openness is not
such that st9 is in Conflict um and I I
understand that members feel that this
has to be located in this location which
is a really important test of st9 um
dm16 is then enabled I think what we do
need as well is condition
that if you are moving for approval and
I think it's probably best that the case
officer Mak some suggestions for
appropriate planning conditions because
given the sensitive landscape um and the
Heritage assets it's really important
that there are some appropriate
conditions
recommended are you going to recommend
those going to do that so um some of the
these conditions have been discussed
with Mr Reed as you would expect so I'll
just run through them one firstly one of
of them would be essentially conditioned
for a landscaping plan and just because
of those sensitive Landscapes to have a
sort of trigger which secures so once we
have a landscaping plan agreed then
planting should take place within uh
potentially prior to the use of the the
turnout um next there would be a
condition which seeks um that no Works
should recomend until the applicant is
secured the Implement implementation of
a written scheme of
Investigation
next okay
yeah I'll just run through the rest of
that's okay um and the next condition
would be essentially a uh post
excavation works and sort of looking at
it um a post
investigation after yeah just interrupt
related to archology can I just
interrupt can these conditions not be
put through the chair and the vice chair
they can if committee are happy if
committee are happy with that and then I
think we'd probably condition um private
use if that's if that's okay with and
then potentially a condition around
temporary structures um given the
testimony about how the site will be
used as a turnout and obviously not a
sound school and therefore um yeah that
might be appropr for me we we can
delegate and officers can agree
conditions with chair and vice chair
that appr c Ben do you want to come back
on that just come back on
condition sorry just come back on
condition one I'm not happy that would
condition one because it is just a yard
area there's no landscape that's going
to be
affected nobody can see it from anywhere
so the application details Landscaping
measures um but essentially not enough
information been provided to come
forward with an appropriate Landscaping
scheme given the the the you know the
proposed bonding and everything else so
the condition what the condition would
do is ask prior to any works
recommencing for Landscaping scheme to
be submitted where the council can
establish whether that's you know
acceptable in line with that condition
it's a very specific condition but as I
said chair chair and vice chair can be
involved in that and essentially then
any of that planting to soften that
impact on the surrounding landscape and
you know the Heritage value Etc that
we've talked about that they would have
to provide that you know prior to the
use of of of of the turnout if that's
acceptable to members well that's not an
unusual condition really because quite
often we have landscape conditions put
on applications chair we are treating
every application on own merits and
there is nothing on the skyline that
could be seen from anywhere and on the
Merit of this application the condition
that you are applying I think is unfair
to the
applicant yeah chair what yes SC 11 yeah
I'm not I'm not happy with starting
spend money on big investigations I mean
there is a a a plan here shown with the
fencing and hedges why can't we just
condition that the plans as shown are
what on the
development you know it's on here as
well it shows the hedes and the banks on
there and in fact most of marting on
there
now okay um thanks counselor I think
what I would say to you there is that
the the drawings that have been
submitted aren't detailed enough they
don't include times of planting when
when the planting is going to be put in
it doesn't include specification on what
kind of boundary treatments it will look
like what what specification of tree or
hedge so it's just a quite a simple
standard condition that we put on a lot
of applications that they have to come
forward with that detail so it can be
agreed
essentially based on what's shown
here based on what's shown here in the
plan because we've all considered the
plans and what's shown on the plan then
so
the condition will be to Dos it's more a
confirmation really of technical detail
and making sure that it's acceptable and
what was the other second condition the
other condition that investigation yeah
so the other conditions related to
conditions which have pretty standard
conditions which have been put forward
by our historic environment officer
essentially asking for you know
conditions related to archaeology and
post investigation again all of this
will be can be provided to the chair and
and um agre I wouldn't have thought we
needed an archaological condition
because we've heard so much about that
this morning haven't we so it's all been
it's already excavated but they are
standard conditions so yes I'm sure that
Council and myself will go through them
and make sure they are correct so I
think that we have given this a long and
detailed
discussion um it has been proposed by
councilor Bush be seconded by councelor
peninon that that the application is
approved quoting
dm16
st7 and
st9 there was a second
um suggestion from councilor hes that
the application was refused but we had
no second for that um proposal so we
will now go to the vote for approval
subject to
[Music]
those sorry
V for approval thank you chair so
Council back
not thank you uh councelor bushby for
councelor haes against councelor
[Music]
leather